speaking of the aliens physical
characteristics roger mobby
or mob i wants to know did the aliens
have a face with a nose and a mouth
yes in this case uh i imagine there's
varieties out there but uh
i would say the nose and the mouth are
probably have similar functions to us
other than perhaps speaking maybe maybe
they sing i don't
know let's talk about some of the visual
aspects of what happened when you were
abducted in 1975 so you mentioned that
visually they look like humans
and i believe on joe rogan you describe
them as wait a minute wait a minute
humanoid humanoid a humanoid does not
mean looking like people in the past on
the street in my town humanoid means two
arms two legs ahead on top eyes in front
uh rather than being looking like a
large crab or a
cockroach or something of that nature
so a lot of people have a
misconception uh the grays are humanoid
and then there were other beings that
are if they were living beings that were
brought in in order to
interrupt my combativeness i was
fighting them and i think the effort was
to complete
healing or repairs that needed to be
made and i i was so terrified i wasn't
allowing that
so those people who were brought into
who i'm referring to you said that they
look like people that would pass as
regular people just at the
in a cityscape you wouldn't be able to
point them out as being different
right
yeah and you know that of course would
uh
fulfill the purpose of getting me to
calm down and cooperate
so that's you thinking perhaps that's
the reason but you're not 100 sure that
if they were there
to be introduced to calm you as an
anxiolytic well it's possible that there
was some sort of ongoing
thing but it definitely changed the
direction of my efforts because
i was terrified of these creatures this
was something i viewed as very
threatening and frightening and i wasn't
about to
cooperate
now
um
many um
stories of encounters with these beings
describe them as being telepathic or
being able to
use mind control
but i i didn't sense anything of that
sort
but um i'm explaining that in my own
personal theory i can't say for sure of
course
is that being hit by that blast of
energy
uh impaired that connection you know
potentially
you're watching this channel because
you're interested in theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is facility with mathematics
as well as discernment of the underlying
physical laws and you may think that
this is beyond you but that's false
brilliant provides polluted explanations
of abstruse phenomenon such as quantum
computing general relativity and even
group theory when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1 cross su 2
cross su 3 that's group theory for
example now this isn't just for
neophytes either for example i have a
degree in math and physics and i still
found some of the intuitions given in
these lessons to vastly aid my
penetration into these subjects for
example electricity and magnetism sign
up today at brilliant.org
tow that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription try four of the lessons at
least don't stop before four and i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you comprehend subjects you
previously had trouble grocking links
are in the description
do you think that some of the human
looking alien not humanoid the
i don't we need to give it a name so
that when i'm referring to it you know
what i'm referring to the human ones
that came in that were there
supposedly to calm you at least so those
ones do you think they were the grays
dressed up do you think they were a
projection did you get the impression
that they were robots
well it would probably would have taken
quite a bit of
telepathic manipulation to make
these smaller creatures appear
to be the human looking ones so i'm
thinking um
they were either really were just earth
people that were cooperating with this
species
or were a creation that they came up
with
in order to
get me to cooperate
when they were doing what they did to
you whatever it was did you get the
sense that it was routine like they've
done this many times before and so they
were cold and distant
no
the lack of communication in hindsight i
think was because
um
telepathic communication was not
possible
in the um
injured state of my
entire body including my brain
and
wasn't because they didn't want to it's
just uh
i was not
in the position to
you know receive or
or
communicate i was basically screaming
like a crazy man so
um that's nothing that encourages
conversation
john doe wants to know do you recall
anything particular about the eyes of
the beings so both either the humanoid
ones or the more human-like ones their
eye colors oh yeah there was something
odd about the human-looking ones in
terms of their eyes
and i never quite put my finger on that
because like i say i wasn't studying
things out
something
unusual
and uh
one thing that stands out to me
concerning the grays was
the stare
it seemed to be penetrating in a very
uncomfortable way
and um
but there were blinks at times
and a lot of people report no blinking
but uh no eyelids but there was
definitely blinking in this case
blinking with their own eyelids or with
the film that came up and then
disappeared like a lizard
it was like their own eyelids
you know on eyes that size it was
quite a
pronounced sort of thing
their eyes
is it primarily black or were you able
to see a direction that they were
looking because there's some white
um
i i didn't see things
like a pupil or anything like that i
presume of course that they were looking
at me because
their faces were pointed towards me
dynamite biz quits wants to know
ask him if the gravity was the same
or different when you woke up so on the
craft did you notice that you were able
to run quicker or slower
good question
i felt
heavy
like i could barely make myself move it
took i took the adrenaline of panic to
be able to
do the things i did
but i took
mistook or whatever interpreted that
weakness to be
um something to do with my injury
um
the improvement in my energy level and
everything when i got outside the craft
um
could could uh indicate that there was
heavier gravity generated inside that
craft for some reason
um
if the beings in their home planet
have a heavier gravity it would also
contribute to a denser atmosphere
more my speculation after 40 years a
denser atmosphere perhaps cutting down
on the amount of light reaching the
surface
of the planet
which might explain
the large eyes large eyes have got to
mean
either of
some kind of an environment where light
is limited i would think um are they
nocturnal maybe that would be the reason
but
if they aren't nocturnal then perhaps
the large eyes come from living
where the atmosphere is heavy denser and
less light reaches the surface
did you notice any strangeness or
anything abnormal about how the aliens
walked so firstly did you see the grays
walk
yes and it was just a real quick light
scurrying um they actually still you
know when i was made contact with one of
them with the back of my arm
it was a lot lighter than i expected it
fell back
uh
very easily
so they just scurry i know that some
people say that they move they shuffle
like
like cicada or like some insect
did you notice any strange movement i
didn't get any insects like compressions
at all was there a difference between
how the grays moved versus the more
human-like
beings
the human-looking ones moved like humans
and
the
grays just moved like very light quick
beings
you also talked about a low rumble as
well as a high-pitched noise when the
craft came near you do you mind
repeating and expanding upon it
well it was um
a frequency that's so low
you you felt it more than uh
heard it or
simultaneously
um
and then a really high high pitch to it
that
and i'm just talking about the ends of
the frequency of the the spectrum of
sound
um
you also mentioned when the craft was
near there was some wind
uh wind yeah the trees were moving as it
or perhaps it was when the craft went
away your friends reported that the
trees oh oh the craft that left me off
uh
created a stir in the air as it passed
some small limbs close by but
that wasn't what you experienced that's
what your friends told you afterwards
oh right but when the craft dropped you
off you were able to look and see when i
was dropped off i was the only
only person there do you well i assume
your friends may have been in too much
of a panic to know if there was any
strange activity when the craft left
such as extreme wind or a special sound
but
um there were other witnesses that saw
the craft depart that reported it to the
sheriff
um
a man who said his uh his job was
military intelligence
deer hunting with his wife
still have the
see back in those days we didn't have
cell phones a lot of this communication
came in actual physical letters and
another one that came
both to me and the sheriff
describing seeing the craft depart
from closer to black canyon lake which
is
near turkey springs